es ist eine dramatische rettungsaktion
aus dem bad die feuerwehr rettet am
späten abend drei männer mit dem
hubschrauber nach der havarie ihres
bootes im mündungsbereich der elbe bei
neufeld in schleswig-holstein versuchen
die drei schiffbrüchigen per fuß das
festland zu erreichen dabei
unterschätzen die männer die gefahr des
watts bild reporter jörg köhnemann ist
mir jetzt zugeschaltet von vor ort und
er hat zwei der glücklich geretteten
weiß ich wir sind hier in
kronprinzenkoog und ich stehe ja mit
zwei geretteten vor dem boot es war kein
segelboot es war ein ganz schnittiges
holzboot ein speed was das wirklich gut
aussieht dass es einigermaßen überlebt
hat nur die scheibe die frontscheibe die
ist gesplittert
neben mir stehen stephan clausen und
timo topic imo thomsen und stephan
clausen beide waren mit an bord beide
können gleich erzählen wie sie diese
dramatische rettung überlebt haben aber
ich muss wirklich sagen nachdem ich mit
beiden gesprochen haben habe
das sind schon ganz schön tax regierung
hier an der küste die ganz schön lange
selber noch in der elbe geschwommen sind
bevor sie überhaupt land oder entließen
hatten und ihr boot umdrehen konnten
da waren sie nämlich sagenhafte eine
stunde noch im wasser und das ist nicht
ein einfaches wasser sondern wir hatten
applaus und wasser es zog also mächtig
an ihn und sie klammerten sich an das
boot dort hinter das umgedreht war und
dass so eine art rettungsring für die
drei waren hier stehen zwei da
forderungen
wir wollten gleich mal etwas über die
rettung an sich wissen
ihr seid rausgefahren abends
[Musik]
ausprobieren
das boot ist neu das boot hat noch
keinen namen jungs wollten eine
spritztour machen um es auszuprobieren
die spritztour wurde dann etwas
dramatisch und etwas länger
ja gegen 18 uhr gesetzt und dann raus
gefahren und als wir aus der einfahrt
rede von meischberger hafen raus waren
und außen auf der elbe quasi da dann
gemerkt dass erwähnt dann doch ein
bisschen stärker wurde als wir uns das
vorstellen konnten und wollten in dem
zuge der noch gleich umbringen beim
umdrehen manövern von achtern eine welle
hinten rein bekommen die schon 60 wasser
mit ins boot gebracht hat dann kam noch
eine das war jetzt keine kleine
klitschen platze wille sondern das war
schon ordentlich
dann kam noch eine keiner seite habe ich
habe alle drei eigentlich das
gleichgewicht verloren und sind dann
seid ihr es mit dem boot über kopf
gegangen
dann trieb das boot kieloben hier drei
watt im wasser das ist dann passiert
eigentlich nur das boot muss her
geschoben schwimmen wollten dann
eigentlich nur noch erstmal zurück ans
ufer versuchen boden unter die füße zu
bekommen dadurch nicht da schon sehr
kalt die elbe ist doch kein warmes
schwimmbecken also ich muss ehrlich
sagen gefüllt war mir da noch gar nicht
so kalt denkmals stress adrenalin und
habe man sich überhaupt keine gedanken
gemacht habe dann einfach nur
funktioniert und deshalb geschwommen und
da ging es noch mit der temperatur
bevor die welle kam war ein großes
schiff in der nähe kam die welle auch
von den großen schiffen ja ist nicht
ausgeschlossen
die waren schon weiter weg wir haben uns
fern von den gehalten aber es waren
bestimmt noch einige einige werk schon
legen die dann ja dann wird ja eine
stunde im wasser unterwegs irgendwann
schlick unter den füßen gespürt ging es
weiter
wir sind dann weiter auf dem lande
draußen gelaufen so weit gekommen ist
will dann einigermaßen wirklich festen
untergrund und dann haben wir zu dritt
das boot wieder versuchen umzudrehen und
auszukippen weil es ja voll war mit
wasser das ist uns dann auch irgendwie
gelungen und so dass das boot dann ist
es wieder schwimmen konnte
dann haben wir weiter vor uns
hergeschoben sind immer weiter richtung
rhein gelaufen
total war der untergrund noch
einigermaßen unterstehe und dann bei den
kräften am ende
das habt ihr dann gesagt dass die mit
der moment als wir keine kraft mehr
hatte
nachdem wir das gut eigentlich abgesetzt
hatten sind wir noch weitergelaufen 200
meter ungefähr weitergelaufen davos
immer schlammiger dann seid ihr da rein
gesunken
hat noch ganz gute zigarette geraucht
dann der notruf und wer hat jetzt nach
denen das wäre das hoch gehalten das
handy
das war ich und dann kann der
hubschrauber und ihr wurde gerettet
genau das sagt feuerwehr auf jeden fall
vielen dank an die feuerwehr ohne die
hätten wir es definitiv nicht gestimmt